yeah that's right sasha we're going to
be expecting some major
wins that are going to be extremely
strong this is why we have upgraded from
that watch to a warning now this is the
highest alert so far when it comes to
the wind department we want to get you
right into it and show you that high
wind warning will kick in at 11 a.m
tomorrow it's going to impact barstow
california param indian springs southern
clark county las vegas north las vegas
definitely going to be included in that
this will officially start at 11 a.m go
on all the way until tuesday morning now
right behind it i want to show you all
of this blue really representing that
wind advisory where we're going to be
tracking also some strong gusts not as
strong like the red portion of it where
we have 50 to 70 mile per hour gusts
here this is focusing on the lake area
definitely going to be tracking those
gusts up to 40 to 55 miles per hour also
kicking in at 11 p.m 11 a.m i should say
outside right now tracking plenty of 70s
and of course calm wind speeds we do
want to show you this evening we do
expect clear conditions the calm before
the storm as of right now we want to go
ahead and toss it over to madison
kimbrough who has more tips on this very
dangerous winds